welcome to the bonus show President
Obama late last week created the largest
ecologically protected area on the
planet when he expanded a national
marine monument in Hawaii to encompass
more than half a million square miles
the president more than quadrupled the
size I I'm gonna have trouble with this
i believe it's pronounced the Papa had
now moku akaya is that at all in the
ballpark valiant effort I would I give
you points for that one ten points the
papa hannam liya kya marine national
monument to over five hundred eighty two
thousand square miles of land and sea in
the northwestern Hawaiian Islands
interestingly president george w bush
not exactly known as the environmental
savior of the planet established the
monument a decade ago President Obama
now growing it even more uh can anyone
really have a problem this I mean I I
know that always there are people who
who will say government just shouldn't
get involved in this but it's not like I
don't believe a hotbed that that
companies wanted to develop for natural
resources I don't think it was a target
for that was it so statistically what I
think will happen here is so in Mobile
is first term you a bit you know he
deported three million immigrants Trump
claims he's gonna get rid of 11 million
yeah so I think Trump ago and expand
this four times yet make it but a two
was it two million square mile Matt
National moment it would be uh 500 yeah
basically try because Trump's gonna win
again he's gonna do everything
absolutely better I one thing I do like
about this is that it includes ocean and
oftentimes when we look at the very
active protection of areas its land and
sometimes you'll see like for example
the Riverkeeper type organizations which
look at rivers what's happening in the
oceans is an absolute train wreck
disaster we know about garbage island
that the sort of small plastic Island uh
that that exists in the Pacific based on
the currents that are out there yeah you
know I I I can't ever help but feel like
it is sort of always too little too late
but we we should applaud this I don't
know what else to say yeah this is a
great thing there are vital ecosystems
that are very unique to this island in
the Pacific and they are going to be
well protected I know they're they're
very much untouched there are some
places like around the Big Island that
have been vastly destroyed due to you
know modern industrial civilization but
for the most part a pristine and they
will hopefully remain that way